the holidays are definitely here so it's
time to start shopping we've teamed up
with Rakuten to make the most out of
your shopping this season welcome to my
office life is so busy that often times
the only time I get to shop is on my
computer in between shoots and so ahead
of cyber monday i wanted to tell you
about a secret savings weapon racket in
you can earn up to 40% cash back at over
3,000 stores with them I just shop with
them at Macy's and I got this beautiful
oil diffuser how cute is this if you're
in my life everyone's getting one of
these for the holidays also stores like
Express and Best Buy you can get
electronics and beauty and fashion they
have everything and not only are you
going to find the gifts that people in
your life are going to love but you're
also gonna love getting a big fat check
in the mail with all the cash back that
you rack up on all your shopping get it
rack up rocket in so make sure you sign
up for rocket in for more amazing deals
and to save on your cyber monday and
holiday shopping